Hello, and welcome back.
Our goal for this class is to break down how to assess scope when developing our environments
for virtual production.
We will also be learning how to import FAB or Quixel Megascans, free fabricated assets
into the engine.
Let's get right into it.
So if you're here, it's probably because you're looking to expand your knowledge in
world building, specifically in a virtual production setting.
Before diving into the engine and starting to design our environment, it's important
to assess the implication of working with a real-time engine.
Because a lot of the steps happening sequentially in a traditional pipeline would actually
evolve organically when working in real-time, and a real engine will allow you to alleviate
a lot of the heavy lifting in that matter.
You'll be able to see the changes in a snap immediately apply to your environment as you
move along.
So after understanding what real-time really means, we need to assess the scope of what
we're aiming to create in our virtual set.
So how much work would that actually involve?
I'm gonna give you a hint.
Something that would help us would be to create for ourselves an asset library, basically
collecting all the assets we expect to be using in our environment based on our story
and overall our direction.
You can ask yourself questions like, which feeling are you trying to recreate with your
environment?
And which composition would best pick that?
Pre-production and production tracking are essential steps of both traditional but also
real-time productions.
So make sure to take your time and have everything ready before diving into environment design
in Unreal Engine.
So once you have an overall idea, have collected a good amount of references and sketched out
your intentions with detailed concept art, you can start breaking all of this down into
an asset list.
You wanna make sure to flag out the assets that would be the longest in focus in your
composition.
Those assets are typically referred to as hero assets in production terms.
In our environment, hero assets will probably hold the highest level of detail or resolution
in our map.
Once you have an asset list, you can start importing or migrating all the assets you'll
be using to develop your environment into the engine.
If using asset packs, you might want to delete assets you wouldn't be using and just keep
those that you would.
This will prevent your project size to overblot with unnecessary items.
Keep in mind that sometimes it might be good to keep similar assets or textures within
a pack at your disposal to create nice variations in your design and not to make it look too
repetitive.
Once everything is imported into the Content Browser, it's a good habit to create a test
scene with all your assets aligned on the floor to get a clear overview of how they
look like and whether there are any migration issues.
When working with external assets, whether modeled and textured by yourself or not, there
are a few things to consider.
First, you wanna make sure those assets are to scale and share the same scaling system.
Remember that centimeters are one-to-one to unreal units.
Your assets are your friend.
The more you build items into separate pieces, the easier it's going to be to A. Create variations
and B. For unreal to swap different level of details based on the distance of thus separated
objects from the camera.
Try not to scale objects that are relatively small and have nanite enabled, rather enlarge
them into a separate DCC and then migrate them into unreal.
If you merge different assets with nanite enabled in Engine, you might add heavy calculations
to the editor.
This is relevant for games but also for virtual production, since the environment displayed
on the LED screens should run at a minimum of 60 or 30 FPS.
Lastly, when using Lumen with thin assets, you could experience light leaking and shadow
artifacts, so make sure to add some volume or depth to them to prevent that.
Alright, let's have a look at the Fab plugin directly in Engine.
Alright, so you could have any project opened up here in the editor, but just make sure
to go under Edit and Plugins and check that the Fab plugin is enabled as well as the Bridge
plugin if you wanna use Quick Fill Bridge.
Today, we're gonna be focusing on Fab only since it contains all the mega scans already.
So you can access that either by the QuickCAD menu down here and then clicking on Fab, or
by clicking on the Add button in the Content Browser and then clicking on Fab.
So the Fab window will open in its default homepage, which will display some featured
Unreal Engine products as well as some Quixel products down here, some UE samples that are
free and you can just download and explore and play around with, some MirrorHemant content
and then some extra content down here.
Here on the left, you can see some different categories you can filter your asset through,
like 3D assets, Materials, Sprites, Decals and more.
And if you ever get lost into a rabbit hole just like filtering through assets, you can
always just click here to go back to your homepage.
Now when looking through assets, you have a few filters at your disposal.
You can filter through the style, so the rendering style or the period and theme of your asset.
You can also check out the compatibility if you're developing for games, some technical
features like whether they're animated or rigged, whether those are blueprint assets,
they're compatible with Nainite or more.
Some formats, if you want them to be compatible with Metahemons, and then you have some more
filters down here like the tags, the price and more.
You can sort them by relevance, rating or other priorities.
And then here, something that could be relevant for you guys is that if you click on these options,
you can choose whether you want to show or not products created with artificial intelligence.
You can also choose whether you want to hide, blur or display mature content.
Okay, then if I wanted to filter through Megafkind's asset only, I could do it by searching through
Quixel and then switching my view from products to publishers, and here you would find the Quixel
products. Now these products need to be purchased, but if you filter through free assets down here
by clicking on price and then flagging the free checkbox, you will be able to see only the free
Quixel assets. If you wanted to filter through Megafkind's only, you can just type Megafkind's
in the search bar, and this will show you results from the Quixel publisher only titled Megafkind's.
So you will be able to find all the Megafkind's assets.
Now for today, I had something specific in mind to download, which is a chicken nugget.
So if I search for chicken, I will be able to find my chicken nugget down here.
That was also wishlisted by me. So if I click down here on the right icon right next to my library,
I'll be able to find my wishlist and I can find my chicken nugget. If I wanted to, I could also
remove it from my library, which I'm going to do right now. And then if I go back one tab,
I will be able to find my chicken research again and wishlisted again if I wanted to.
So if I click on this chicken nugget, I will get access to some further details on this asset.
So down here, you can choose the quality you want to download this asset in, whether you want it low,
medium, high, or low, which is uncompressed. Make sure to choose the resolution of the assets you
download wisely based on your environment composition. So if this chicken nugget was going to be a
hero asset, I will probably download it as raw or high quality. But if it were an asset far in the
background that would be seen really small in the camera, then I'll probably choose something like a
low quality. Okay, so if we scroll down in our asset details, we can find here some included
formats. Right now you can see that I don't have access to the UF add or the C brush formats,
because we're within the Unreal editor. But if I click on FBX, I can find some details on the
total amount of triangles and vertices, as well as the overall size of this asset and the textures
that it will come with. All right, so now that I've chosen my asset, as well as the quality that I
want to download it in, I can just click on add to project. My asset will be downloaded.
And then Unreal Engine will open my downloaded asset directly into the content browser. So if I
double click here, I will find my static mesh, and I can open it up if I wanted to.
All right, let's go back to our slides for a moment. All right, so when importing external assets from
FAB, you not only want to make sure to download the correct resolution, but also set up your level
of detail wisely, because this could have a high impact on your scenes. Now, if you're using Nanite,
things would be a little different, and we'll be talking about it in the next video. If Nanite is
disabled, the LOD would swap based on the distance of the object from your camera. You can see here
in the slide, I outlined a few steps that you can take to customize the level of detail of your
asset. Let's go back to the engine and see this option in further depth. All right, first of all,
by right clicking on any static mesh actor in the content browser, we can check up here whether Nanite
is toggled on or off and disable it if we wanted to. Now, this chicken nugget has only one level
of detail, so it wouldn't be a good example to show you how to set up different LODs. So I'm going
to close it down and then just click on this rock here in my environment. And then in the details
panel, I will just double click on the assigned actor to open the static mesh editor up. And here
we can see our boulder. Now, in the details panel, I can see that Nanite is enabled on it. So I'm
going to disable it just to get access to the different LOD options and to show you. Now, under
the LOD picker section, you can see that LOD is set to auto. This means that if I distance myself
from the object with the camera, the different LODs will automatically swap to optimize my viewport.
And you can see as I go back with my camera that the current screen size of the object will decrease,
as well as the fallback triangles and vertices. Now, if you wanted to, we could force the editor to
use just one specific LOD we have here at our disposal. The LOD zero would have the best quality
and the LOD four would be the most optimized. So if I switch this to all LOD form, you can see that
my fallback triangles lower to 600 and vertices to 500 compared to an LOD zero of 10,000 and 5,000
vertices. Now in virtual production, this could be relevant because you might want to isolate the
hero asset to an LOD of zero, then perhaps the rest of the assets or assets that are further away
from the camera to an LOD of four, for example, then if we wanted to, we can just activate this
custom checkbox and we would be able to deactivate specific LODs on this asset. So if we wanted to
keep it to a high resolution range, then we could disable LOD four, three and two. Now, even if we
zoomed back from the object, the resolution will still stay on a high level versus if we did the
opposite, if we just kept the LOD three, four and two, then we would just be using those three types
of LODs. Now turning them all on again, if I scroll down here, you can see that I will get access
to the specific details and settings to all the different LODs, the LOD zero, one, two, three and
four. And then if I open up the reduction settings menu, you can see that you have it on all the
different LODs, you can actually choose the percent of triangles you want to have on the static mesh
on this specific LOD. So for example, for the LOD four, you would have the six percent of the total
vertices and then on the LOD zero, you would have a hundred percent triangles. When trying to optimize
the scene for virtual production, sometimes even the LOD four settings might still be too detailed
and in that case, it's really useful to use this reduction settings option to reduce the geometry
of the mesh at this specific LOD. This is useful to optimize your map, especially if you find yourself
unable to hit that 30 or 60 FPS mark on the LOD screens. Now if I scroll down even more, you can
see that you can assign a different LOD group based on the type of prop or asset that this is.
And then down here, you can see that you can choose the number of LODs you want to use,
as well as choosing whether you want to automatically compute the LOD distances or not. So if you turn
this off, you will get access to the screen size option here to the different LODs and
define the screen size that the object needs to have in the viewport when swapping to the different
LODs. All right, I hope this provided you with a good overview on the different LOD settings that
we have at our disposal in the static mesh editor. And now we're going to switch back to our slides
to conclude this video. All right, that was it for this class. Shout out to Sean Spitzer for
the creation of these slides. And I want to also thank Brandon Jones and King Chen for allowing us
to display their concept art in the beginning slides of this presentation. You can find some
additional documentation at this link if you're interested in learning more about FEB and the
Quixel Bridge plugin for Unreal Engine. Thanks for sticking around and in the next course, we'll be
learning some basic lighting concepts and how they work together with Nanite. Will I see you there?
All right, bye.